[Music]
mark is in salt lake city hey mark
what's up
hi i'm doing good um
i just have some issues with some family
and money okay
uh my parents had given me 200k for a
house
that we ended up buying because they're
ailing in age
and they couldn't maintain the property
they had and my other siblings weren't
really helping
and so it was easier for him to move
closer and be with us
so i was perfectly fine and i said look
so you took a 200 000 gift from them and
then you bought a house so you could
take care of them
so many words yes i already had
already paid off
everything basically that home wouldn't
work for them so i had to purchase the
newer home to
make it more accessible for them for
their age and then their requirements
like their vehicles and other things of
that nature
how old are your parents
in their 80s
okay
okay sounds like you've done a very nice
thing and they helped
provide for you to take care of them so
where did it blow up
speak directly into your phone mark
sorry we're having a hard time hearing
you they were uh being racist and sexist
and i gave them basically three chances
to stop because i have two kids at home
so essentially since they couldn't abide
by that i said that's fine you can have
the top half i'll have the bottom half
and
you know if you ever need anything let
me know
so
essentially
um i overheard
my wife uh well she told me she
overheard them because they're hard of
hearing
they were saying that they were afraid
that
i was going to murder them and take
their money
but they were going to ask for their
200k back
[Music]
okay so women they were being racist and
sexist
and they're 80 years old
well it's not the fact that they needed
to change i didn't ask that i just said
like if like you know you're coming
upstairs and you have a racist sex you
have to talk into your phone you're
mumbling
yeah i said if you're gonna say sexist
and raise those things as a tv
you know you got to be cognizant there's
two little children running around
they're going to hear that you got to
stop
politely and so you know that was kind
of taken care of
how old are you
i am 30
uh almost 40 years old
okay so what are you going to do
well i don't know you know i mean
so the 200k
you know it was essentially given and i
didn't want it i said no thank you i'll
take care of it myself and then it
became an ultimatum where they said we
we give it to you and we're not going to
do it number one and then number two it
helps us give us say in the house which
was fine i was like you know you're
welcome to put up and do whatever you
want on your floor your you know i can't
have it downstairs because i have two
little ones and i have to make sure that
they're safe
so if something's unsafe you know i just
can't have it but when did all this blow
up
so it's just it's been a progression
over years and then
when did one of this whole thing blow up
and they move upstairs and decide you
were going to kill them for their money
what no no no so the thing is is um
they've been upstairs the whole time no
i mean you ran them upstairs and told
them to go away because they were
yelling nicer stuff at the television
no no no no that was the the upstairs is
more um you know it has the master
bedroom it has a bathroom you told me
that you told them to go upstairs if
they couldn't behave
but no see they automatically live
upstairs and we would come up for dinner
and things of that nature oh so they
have to stay up there okay then you're
running no no no so they they have
they're more than welcome to come down
but again they're elderly so coming down
the stairs isn't really an option you're
missing the point i'm asking when this
big conversation where you all had got
crossways happen a week ago a day ago a
month ago
again yeah i gave them three chances and
what was the third strike
finally
what was the third strike
so the third strike was when i was um
essentially i missed uh we tried to have
dinner on sundays
together
and so
i was running late there was an accident
on the freeway i called them told them i
wasn't gonna make it
and then on the way home i got a phone
call from my kids boy scout saying hey
we changed the meeting happens tonight
can you make it and i said i'll give it
a shot so i get home i have just enough
time to drop off kids two days ago look
this is uh
three months ago okay i said look okay
so you've been living in this tent just
stop i don't hear all that you've been
living in this tension for three months
yeah well in a way because essentially
you need to sell the house
and they need to go on their way
and you need to give them 200k
and then you go back to your other
property or something like your other
property the equivalent thereof and they
need to have their own life
well i understand and that's the easy
way to say it but again i mean you don't
just get to sell a property
buy a house that you want that's going
to work for you instantly the market
here isn't like that it's not oh here
you go you know this is
you know what you're going to get and
walk away so essentially they pawned the
200k off on me and i said i don't want
it yeah but you have crazy people in the
upstairs of your house
well they turned around and said look
here's your inheritance
your two other brothers i heard all that
you have crazy people in the upstairs of
your house who are yelling racial
epitaphs at the television and they're
telling other people that you're gonna
kill them
yeah this is not going well have you
noticed that it's irrational i don't
know what to do with the irrational i i
do get rid of it
yeah but i mean then where how do i come
up with 200k you sell the house
isn't it not in the equity of the house
well so no i i went ahead because we
we're we are very well financially off
okay what's your house worth
we paid about let's just round it to
900k it's worth 900k and what do you owe
on it
nothing
sell the house hand them 200k and go buy
a 700 000 house
it's really not rocket science mark
well i understand but
okay it sounds like it's hard for you
emotionally but the actual step is is
easy we're telling you sell the house
that's it you're saying it can't be done
well the thing is is again i mean yeah
you want me to get your 80 year old
crazy parents to behave like they're
supposed to behave and i can't help you
with that yeah i'm well that's not what
i'm asking my question is is really
ethically do they deserve the 200k yes
they're the ones who gave it to me i
know but you don't need the money you
just told us you're so financially well
off you don't need the money
i agree this is not about the money
yeah you could keep the money if you
want but i got it you got to give them
the money so they can go buy a nursing
home or go pla find a place live with
your brother or something they have
plenty go drive somebody else
crazy okay i'd be done with this i'd
give them 200 yeah
you tried to set some boundaries inside
your own home and it didn't work because
people who don't like boundaries
generally it's shocking they don't like
boundaries
and so that's what happened they went
bananas when you drew a line in the sand
okay there's no scenario where they stay
there and it all just works out
well i don't think they should you know
i i agree with you 100 but you want to
kick them out and keep the 200k that's
not going to work either
no because i'm not they're deciding to
leave and i'm okay with that you know
what i mean oh are they leaving
well they so i just found out today
that's right
today
oh well we're gonna get a place
mean okay i help you i mean i'm not here
to hinder you i'm here to right i was
here always here to help right
right well yeah help them get out and
get a place and and do you have 200 000
cash laying around
no i mean i have
like we in our savings have 80. okay you
know okay and so we have that but you
know i have kids school to pay for me
um i mean really that's the only
bill i have but you have a house you
don't need now if they move out well we
do i mean because we still need the
space
you you don't need the entire house that
holds two people in the upstairs that
aren't there anymore dude
um
and so
i
okay what would i do um i think you're
highly emotional
and you're having a real problem
thinking through this clearly
so i'll tell you what i would do i'd
sell my house i'd hand them 200k
i wouldn't be in a big hurry to do it
but i do it reasonably and judiciously